question what value does more bodies
bring to a guy
does it have to bring value yeah no I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying when when a
girl Banner
predisposition to be attracted to Purity
and youth what do you mean by that like
all throughout throughout all of history
like the most powerful men had
concubines of virgins right that would
be attributed to men wanting or people
in those positions one is claiming as
much power as possible and the more most
power you can have is over a submissive
pure female right it doesn't necessarily
right but I'm saying like we're they're
attracted to Youth and Purity and they
can't undo that but that's that's a
power based mindset right and that power
is what we kind of crave through a
survival mindset right when we're trying
the person who has the most power is the
most likely to survive right and so when
we're in that frame of mind that makes
sense but that's not the world that we
kind of really live in anymore it's not
really based around survival it's not
based around this calling for power
until